I'm joined today by Tyler van der wiel
who's a professor of Epidemiology at the
Harvard School of Public Health and
studies associations between religious
participation and health you actually
have a recent study on this issue and it
had some interesting correlations
between women's religious service
attendants and health outcomes get give
our audience sort of an overview of what
you found yeah so we published a few
studies in the last couple of months
which showed that women who regularly
attend religious services generally have
better health we found for example that
women who were attending religious
services more than once a week were
about thirty three percent less likely
to die in 16 years of follow-up than
those not attending at all those who
were attending weekly about twenty six
percent less likely to die and follow up
in those attending a less than weekly
maybe one to three times a month were
about thirteen percent less likely to
die during follow-up and we also looked
at em suicide and depression as as
outcomes and women who were regularly
attending services were about five times
less likely to commit suicide and about
thirty percent likely and less likely to
subsequently become depressed so they
were fairly a substantial associations
can you talk a little bit about with a
study like this how we can distinguish
between causation or correlation as well
as sort of third variables that could be
factors so as an example I guess what
I'm sort of getting to is how could we
know that the most in important factor
that correlates to for example of
mortality is church attendance versus
for example some other factor which
encourages or allows people to go to
church more that might actually be the
causal factor associated with the
reduced mortality rate how is a
scientist can we explore those
possibilities yeah so that's a very good
question and it's what I spend most of
my life and research trying to sort out
and there are really two concerns here
one which you had had mentioned is how
do we know it's not some some third
factor may be married people are more
likely to attend religious services and
are also more likely to live longer how
do we know it's not just marriage or how
do we know it's not just having a higher
income and what we do is we try to
control for those other variables in the
analysis so we controlled for race
education marital status and and
importantly we also controlled for a
baseline health whether they were
depressed at the beginning of the study
whether they had a cardiovascular
condition and controlling for health at
the beginning is also important to
address another potential concern which
is which is that of reverse causation
the worry that it's one finds these
associations simply because it's only
those who are healthy who can actually
attend services and so we try to control
for health it they slide in the study
too and address that the other thing we
do and this is what the real advance was
of this study compared to all prior
studies on this topic is we measured
religious service attendants and health
repeatedly over time and so we can see
which changes and proceeded which others
and so using that sort of data and
methods to address these concerns we
were able to provide evidence that this
relationship was causal even after
controlling for all of these other
variables even looking at the temporal
changes over time the the associations
were quite robust they they held up so
one can't really prove causality with
data of the sort but one can provide
evidence for it and our methods in our
data and suggest the evidence here is
fairly strong when you talk about
adjusting for baseline health I'm
curious as to whether that include sort
of some of the most important factors uh
in terms of lifestyle with regard to
health in other words how was diet
considered in that where diet may be
something that doesn't show in baseline
health conditions but over a period of
observation a
or diet or better diet for example can
start to have health repercussions how
might something like that be a accounted
for in a study like this yeah so we did
control for diet quality as well along
with them smoking social support at
baseline we we made adjustment for all
of those factors with something like
smoking it's quite interesting because
those who smoke regularly are less
likely to attend religious services but
it's also the case that those who attend
religious services and our smoking are
subsequently if they attend religious
service is more likely to stop smoking
so you get effects in both directions
and once again the only way to really
sort through that is by collecting data
repeatedly over time on both religious
service attendants and on something like
smoking or diet or social support so the
way you try to handle these types of
issues is you control for or adjust all
of for all of the behaviors and factors
prior to the religious service
attendants measure but not the ones
subsequent to the religious service
attendants measure that you're looking
at so you can actually get at the effect
of religious service attendants itself
on these other subsequent behaviors and
pathways so once again the temporal
ordering of the data that's collected is
very important when people hear this
conversation I will no doubt get emails
from people saying but wait wait wait is
the argument that belief in God or
religiosity in some way are correlated
or causally related to better health to
be very clear that's not at all what
this study says right this is
specifically related to church
attendance that's right this study was
looking specifically at religious
service attendants and in another study
which will be published in this fall we
also looked at measures of religious or
spiritual identity and religious coping
to deal with stress and private
practices such as prayer and we found
those were much more weakly associated
with
with better health there was still some
Association but it was much weaker than
was the case for religious service
attendant so there seems to be something
very powerful about the communal
religious experience something far more
powerful than than private practice with
regard to beliefs we actually really
don't have very good data hundred
religious beliefs in and and health
there is one intriguing cross-sectional
study so very very weak designed for
trying to establish causality but the
results are intriguing which suggested
that belief in life after death was
associated with better mental health
outcomes but we need much better data
data like the type that was in our study
on religious service attendants to more
accurately assess the and health effects
of different religious belief so I would
say that the the date and the studies on
on that and really haven't good studies
really haven't appeared yes that would
be media I mean I guess certainly we can
all imagine how belief in life after
death could s wage many anxieties in the
real world for people so what I what I
I'm sort of getting to and I came away
with from looking at the details of the
study is that the the data seem to
correlate pretty significantly with what
we see in the studies that we have about
the impact of for example regular
meditation practice as as one a
possibility and that I would imagine
that if we also looked at a population
and said okay what about participation
in regular social coed sports leagues
for example or something like that that
we would see very similar types of
correlations and I'm sort of left with
the question whether what we're really
talking about here is that these types
of engagements and connections to
community aside from scriptural beliefs
are really what seems to be correlated
with and at least in this particular
case you're arguing causally related
with lower mortality and less anxiety
depression etceteras is that a sort of
generally fair assessment it's a very
good question and certainly the social
component of religious service
attendance is and very important and we
we looked at what the different
mechanisms might be for relating
religious service attendants to better
better health and and social support did
explain some of it probably about a
quarter so some but there do seem to the
other pathways as well if you look at
other forms of social participation like
showing up for a a card game or being
involved in a political organization and
those are also associated with with
better health the association's tend to
not be quite as strong as they are with
religious service attendants but but
they're certainly there is well my
speculation though we don't have good
data on this is that social groups which
have not simply a common place to meet
but also a shared set of values and a
common mission and purpose are probably
going to have stronger effects on health
than simply say showing up for a regular
card game so I do think the social
aspect of it provision of social support
is important for other social
organizations and for religious service
attendants but it's it's certainly not
the and the only mechanism so when we
try to look at why this association
appeared to be their social support was
important but there were other things
those who attended religious services I
think because of the social and
behavioral norms present were less
likely to smoke were more likely to quit
smoking if they already smoked and that
goes on to affect health and those who
attended services I think perhaps
because of the message of faith or hope
at these services we're more optimistic
and less likely to subsequently become
depressed and we know that that also
affects health and other mechanisms that
have been proposed in the literature and
blued and religious service is giving
when we're meeting in purpose in life
which has been shown to affect health
and and perhaps by attending religious
services and trying to follow the
practices of these groups one develops
of disciplines health control which is
good for health and other outcomes as
well so I think there are many different
pathways which by which religious
service attendants a fax health and I
think the reason we're finding fairly
large associations is the
cuz there are so many different pathways
it's not just one thing it's not just
social support social supports important
but there are these other mechanisms as
well very very interesting we've been
speaking with professor of Epidemiology
Tyler van der wiel from the Harvard
School of Public Health thanks so much
for talking to us about the study thank
you David